Jericho story is in and out of prison
more than half his life he's got no
impulse control he's unable to calculate
the consequences of his actions there's
a total lack of empathy for anybody or
anything he feels nothing
you know boy my head your name is Bill
Pope you're an intelligence officer the
CIA the daughters named Emma your wife
Gill huh thank you to them hey hey
look at me pay attention Yanis true
dutch program he needed protection
remember you got him to the safe house
where did you put it
that is all we need to know
I need you to remember I don't remember
nothing
you don't know me but I know you
war
they stop your husband in my head why
looking for details that he knew before
he was killed
Washington burning machine would be
graveyards people will understand there
is a better way to route this world
having her man in my head made me feel
right can you feel what Billy felt and
loves you
blessed chance are they done
they mess with me not they knew what to
get
but they were wrong
we are feeling a hundred knives hidden
half tons in potassium is a [ __ ]
hundreds zips just eats